Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I am so happy to tell you that today, my
dream came true. I can’t believe it. So,
what happened? I am going to show you my new
paper that just came out. This is a short
Comment article published in Nature Physics,
where I had the opportunity to be a bit of an
ambassador for the computer graphics research
community. You see, this is a small field,
but it has so many absolutely amazing papers,
I am really honored for the opportunity to show
them to the entire world. So, let’s marvel
together today as you’ll see some amazing
papers throughout this video. For instance, what
about this one? What are we seeing here? Yes,
what you see here is a physics simulation from a
previous episode that is so detailed, it is almost
indistinguishable from reality. So, what you
are seeing here should be absolutely impossible.
Why is that? Well, to find out, we are going
to look at two different branches of fluid
simulations. Scientists who work in the area
of computational fluid dynamics have been able
to write such simulations for more than 60 years
now, and these are the really rigorous simulations
that can accurately tell how nature works in
hypothetical situations. This is super useful,
for instance, for wind tunnel tests for cars,
testing different aircraft and turbine designs,
and more. However, these simulations can
easily take from days to weeks to compute.
Now, here is the other branch. Yes, that
is computer graphics. What is the goal for
computer graphics simulation research? Well,
the goal is exactly what you see here. Yes,
for us graphics people, a simulation does not need
to be perfect. The goal is to create a simulation
that is good enough to fool the human eye. These
are excellent for feature-length movies, virtual
worlds, quick visualizations, and more. And
here is the best part, in return, most computer
graphics techniques don’t run from days to weeks,
they run in a few minutes to a few hours at most.
So, computational fluid dynamics, slow but
rigorous, computer graphics, fast but approximate.
These are two completely different branches.
Now, of course, any self-respecting Scholar
would now ask, okay, but Károly, how do you
optimize an algorithm that took weeks to run,
to now run in a matter of minutes? Well,
here are two amazing ideas to perform that.
One is spatial adaptivity. What does
that do? Well, it does this! Oh yes,
it allocates most of our computational
resources to regions where the real
action happens. You see these more turbulent
regions with dark blue. The orange or yellow
parts indicate calmer regions where we can
get away with less computation. You see,
this is an approximate model, but a really
good one which speeds up the computation
a great deal at a typically small cost. The
hallmark of a good computer graphics paper.
Two, in my opinion, this is one of the most
beautiful papers in all of computer graphics,
Surface-Only Liquids. Legendary work. Here,
we lean on the observation that most of the
interesting detail in a fluid simulation
is visible on the surface of the liquids,
so why not concentrate on that. Now, of course,
this is easier said than done, and
this work really pulled it off.
But, we are not stopping here. We can also use
this amazing paper to add realistic bubbles to
a simulation. And you will see in a moment that
it greatly enhances the realism of these videos.
Look at that. I absolutely love
it. If the video ends here,
it is because I cannot stop looking
at and running these simulations.
Okay, it took a while, but I am back, I have
recovered. So, the key to this work is that
it does not do the full surface-tension
calculations that are typically required
for simulating bubbles, no-no. That would be
prohibitively expensive. It just says that look,
bubbles typically appear in regions where air
gets trapped by the fluid. And it also proposes
an algorithm to find these regions. And the
algorithm is so simple, I could not believe
my eyes. I thought that this was some kind of a
prank. It turns out, we only need to look at the
curvature of the fluid, and only nearby, which
is really cheap, simple and fast. And it really
works! I can’t believe it. Once again, this
is an approximate solution, not the real deal,
but it is extremely simple and fast, and it can
even be added as a post-processing step to a
simulation that is already finished without
the bubbles. How cool is that? Loving it!
Now wait, we just said that surface-tension
computations are out of reach. That just costs
too much. Or, does it? Here is an incredible
graphics paper from last year that does just
that. So what is all this surface-tension thing
good for? Well, for instance, it can simulate
this paperclip floating on water. That is quite
remarkable because the density of the paperclip
is 8 times as much as the water itself, and
yet, it still sits on top of the water. We
can also drop a bunch of cherries into water and
milk and get these beautiful simulations. Yes,
these are not real videos, these are all simulated
on a computer. Can you tell the difference? I’d
love to know, let me know in the comments below!
And get this, for simpler scenes, we only need to
wait for a few seconds for each frame. That
is insanity. I told you that there are some
magical works within computer graphics. I am so
happy for the opportunity to share them with you!
However, wait a second. Remember, we
said that these graphics works are fast
and approximate. But is this really true?
Can they really hold the candle to these
rigorous computational fluid dynamics
simulations that are super accurate,
but take so long? That is impossible,
right? A quick simulation on our home
computer cannot possibly tell us anything
new about aircraft designs, can it? Well,
hold on to your papers, because it can! And it
not only can, but you are already looking at it!
This is a devilishly difficult test, a real
aerodynamic simulation in a wind tunnel. In
these cases, getting really accurate results is
critical. For instance, here we would like to
see that if we were to add a spoiler to this car,
how much of an aerodynamic advantage we would get
in return. Here are the results from the real wind
tunnel test, and now, let’s see how the new method
compares. Wow. Goodness! It is not perfect by any
means, but seems accurate enough that we can see
the wake flow of the car clearly enough so that
we can make an informed decision on that spoiler.
Yes, this, and even more is possible with computer
graphics algorithms. These approximate solutions
became so accurate and so fast, that we are seeing
these two seemingly completely different branches,
computational fluid dynamics, and computer
graphics getting closer and closer to each
other. Even just a couple years ago, I did not
dare to think that this would ever be possible.
And yet, these fast and predictive
simulations are within arm’s reach,
and just a couple more papers down the line,
and we might be able to enter a world where
an engineer is able to test new ideas in aircraft
design every few minutes. What a time to be alive!
So, all this came about because I am worried that
as the field of computer graphics is so small,
there are some true gems out there, and if we
don’t talk about these works, I am afraid that
almost no one will. And this is why Two Minute
Papers, and this paper came into existence. And
I am so happy to have a Comment paper accepted
to Nature Physics, and now, to be able to show
it to you. By the way, the paper is a quick
read, and you can read it for free through
the link in the video description. I think we are
getting so close to real life-like simulations,
everyone has to hear about it. So cool! If
you wish to help me spread the word about
these incredible works, please consider sharing
this with your friends and tweeting about it.
I would also like to send a big thank you for
this amazing opportunity to write this paper,
and to Christopher Batty who sent super
useful comments. So, what do you think?
What would you use these techniques
for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!